investigation has been launched into
devon and cornwall police after it was
revealed the plymouth gunman had his
weapon taken away only for it to be
returned just a few weeks ago
jake davidson's shotgun and firearms
certificate were confiscated last
december following an allegation of
assault
on thursday evening the 22 year old
killed five people including his own
mother before turning the gun on himself
a three-year-old girl and her father
were also amongst the dead
our crime correspondent martin brunt
reports
on a balmy summer's evening a motorist
dashboard camera caught a chilling
moment in an unfolding horror
a figure crouches over a shot victim a
woman who later died in hospital
down the road no one else seemed aware
of what was happening
two weeks earlier on his own youtube
channel gunman jake davison was clearly
a troubled young man
i just don't have any willpower to do
anything anymore
you know i know a lot of people say oh
that's weak minded that's pathetic but
dude
it's it's like how many years i've been
working out
how many years i've been wanting and
dealing with all these frustrations
davidson's neighbors soon learned how he
had dealt with his frustrations
just after six my son was up there
obviously with his friends at the dog
park
he said he heard some either some a big
bang
he said he um
don't know if somebody got shot or
stabbed so he came running back to me
told me we ran up times we got up there
police were on scene
and obviously they were doing cpr on
some person don't know if it's a lady or
a man
i heard a bit of a commotion at the back
and helicopters coming an alicopter came
over and and landed in the field and
then was another helicopter outside
hovering and then going around and it
was police cars going up and down the
street and
saren's everywhere and all of a sudden
that they
all went up here a bit of drive behind
me and
just literally
covered the place crane operator jake
davison shot dead five victims and
wounded two others
his first victim was his mother maxine
she was 51. he kicked open her door
before shooting her
for 12 minutes he roamed nearby streets
he shot dead three-year-old sophie
martin and her father lee
he killed 59 year old stephen washington
then he shot kate shepard who died in
hospital she was 66
the bodybuilder shot himself dead as
armed police arrived
davison's shotgun was taken off him last
year after an assault allegation but
police gave it back to him a month ago
the chief constable said it wasn't
unusual to take away a gun and then
return it we do take firearms licenses
away from people when they come to
notice the police or family members
raise concerns later to restore them
once we're assured that will form part
of the inquiry
on social media jake davison talked
about guns and watched videos about guns
witnesses said he killed his victims
with a pump action shotgun
today police will renew appeals for more
witnesses
and they'll continue to investigate jake
davison's background to understand what
prompted the shootings
but they know a clear motive may never
emerge
martin brunt sky news plymouth
well the vigil was held in plymouth last
night for the victims of the shooting
and there has been an outpouring of
grief with churches opening their doors
to offer a space for prayer and
reflection
ashley huruneg reports from plymouth
these families have witnessed
unspeakable horrors
they are all weaving here
[Music]
for those that witnessed the attack like
13 year old lily it's a haunting memory
i didn't expect it at all how are people
feeling today
um
i told my cousin not to worry about it
he said he's not at all
um and then i feel a little bit okay i
had a nightmare last night about it
um yeah i've got i had a dream that i
got killed
in shock and shaken just like abby who's
lived in this part of plymouth her whole
life as a mum of three she can't stop
thinking about the youngest victim a
three-year-old girl that could have been
my son or my daughter or my other son
that got shot
and it's like now i won't got pleaded
with him i'm terrified to go at that end
because
it could happen again like no one can
turn and say now it never happened again
no one thought it would happen the first
time captain would say it's not gonna
happen the second time or third time
because no one knows
a thought too raw to erase
some are seeking support and others are
finding solace in sharing but most
importantly
let us pray for the souls
of the faithful department
healing will take time
these things aren't settled quickly are
they
for some people their lives have been
changed forever through what's happened
and the community itself certainly will
take some time to come to terms with
with all that we've experienced
24 hours after their deaths hundreds
gathered in their memory collective
silence allowed for collective
reflection but disbelief lingers
the loss of the 12th of august will be
forever remembered by this city as one
of the darkest days in plymouth's
history
horror night sky news in plymouth
well videos posted on youtube by the
gunman indicate he identified with the
in-cell or involuntary celibate movement
it's an online subculture involving men
who express resentment and hostility to
women a home affairs correspondent mark
white reports
they they do not want need or find
average men
attractive
from his video posted clear plymouth
gunman jake davison was deeply resentful
of his lack of success with the opposite
sex
in this day and age women have nothing
but options
at the very least his videos show
sympathy and understanding for those
involved in the so-called end cell
movement of involuntary celibate men who
are deeply hostile towards those
particularly women who are sexually
active
the intel movement first rose to
international prominence in 2014 when
eliot roger murdered six students at the
university of california all because he
couldn't secure a relationship i've been
forced to endure an existence
of loneliness
rejection
and unfulfilled desires
in canada in 2018 alec minassian who
boasted of being an in-cell used a van
to knock down and kill ten people in
toronto
they are
coming together in forums
and promote really deeply dehumanizing
rhetoric towards women
a sense of their own entitlement a sense
of injustice in the uk recent separate
investigations prevented these two men
linked to the incel movement from
carrying out violent action anwar druik
and oliver bell had both spoken of their
humiliation and frustration with the
opposite sex and had attempted to make
explosives
if plymouth killer jake davison was in
any way motivated by the incel movement
it will be a huge concern to authorities
as they try to track this growing
subculture of young men whose sexual
loneliness and rage is increasingly
manifesting in violence
mark white sky news
british troops have been deployed to
afghanistan to bring home uk nationals
and embassy staff
the taliban have now taken control of
more than two-thirds of afghanistan's
provincial capitals and the situation
the u.n has warned is spinning out of
control
it comes amid fears the assault on kabul
could just be days away well this map
shows afghanistan four months ago when
the u.s started to withdraw the areas
controlled by the taliban in red and uh
by the government by in blue you see
the change now with the government areas
in blue shrinking
kabul is almost surrounded the taliban
taking control of kalaipool harat's
capital and kandahar
if we put the map side by side you can
see the speed of the taliban advance
even more clearly now as well as
afghanistan's second biggest city
kandahar falling lash kaga in helmand
province has also been overrun
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
reports from kabul
for thousands upon thousands of people
this is certainly the most important
airport in the world right now
with the taliban advances and all routes
to the capital under their control hamad
karzai airport is the only way to get
supplies in more importantly it's the
only way out
the american embassy that dominates the
center of town will move its operations
to the airport joining u.s and british
military british embassy staff will
follow suit
short of a rethink it is the end game
impressive looking afghan army convoys
still crisscross kabul but recent events
suggest it's a veneer the military has
capitulated
thousands of embassy staff ngos and
foreign nationals will start their
journeys out from the green zone and the
fortified mansions that have been home
for two decades
passing kabul residents who have no
choice but to stay they'll all travel on
the airport road
guarded by british and american soldiers
to the gates
finally inside they'll be processed and
prepared for departure behind the high
blast walls and gun turrets of the
airport complex
planning for the exit is underway it
needs to be the taliban are closing in
so taliban have now taken logar province
its borders are only about 37 miles down
the road behind me and it feels
inevitable now that kabul will fall
the city is very much divided between
those who can leave or at least hope
they can leave and those who know they
can't
means this place is very tense now
crowding around computers manned by
experts groups of men are struggling to
fill out the application forms for
afghans who have worked for the
international community
security guards translators and a whole
array of jobs
the taliban will kill them
these visas are their only passage to
safety
but the process has been slow and time
is running out
ali worked as a u.s special forces
translator from 2011. he still hasn't
got permission to travel he's
representative of so many who are so
desperate
we serve for the american forces we
serve for the u.s and isil forces for
the coalition forces they have to take
care about us
it is our turn
to be helped
we help them you know we save their
lives
we were the people who communicate with
two cultures
otherwise without
interpreters they did nothing
and so so now you're abandoned and
scared yes
the vast majority of ordinary afghans
are slowly but surely preparing
themselves for the retaking of their
city by the taliban
on high ground in kabul the famous kite
runners know all too well their fun will
likely be stopped by the taliban
as that day nears the skies reverberate
to the sounds of helicopters
war machines of a war that seems lost
mr ramsey sky news kabul
foreign affairs editor debra haynes who
joins us now look with all of this we
know the government is taking it
seriously we know there's been a cobra
meeting is it likely to lead to any sort
of change in our current policy
well yes boris johnson yesterday had
that emergency meeting which is a sign
of the absolute crisis that this
government is facing when they're
looking at the afghan government that
they've supported for the last 20 years
crumbling in the face of this taliban
advance but from the words of the prime
minister last night it looks like
there's no change of policy the the
belief the understanding is that there
is no military solution that they can
impose on afghanistan clearly the
taliban takeover now seems inevitable
but it's interesting to note that this
just wasn't what officials were saying
even a week ago a week ago the head of
the uk's armed forces general sir nick
carter
wrote an opinion piece in the times
saying it's too soon to write off the
afghan security forces and the key is to
keep hold of the provincial capitals and
he named herat and also that southern
city of kandahar within days both of
them as well as many others had fallen
it does seem that this taliban advance
had not been predicted by even the most
senior and deep experts on afghanistan
and that really does call into question
what were people
what what were officials thinking that
their plans in afghanistan were doing in
terms of a long-term effect we know from
the defense secretary the uk defense
secretary that the uk
is deeply unhappy with the us decision
to call time on afghanistan and to pull
troops out in the way that joe biden did
coming on the back of president
then president trump's decision to
strike a deal with the taliban last year
but it does seem as though for the uk at
least they are accepting resign to the
fact that they aren't going to be able
to reverse this tide and so now the
focus really is about safety about
ensuring the security of british
diplomats other british nationals in
kabul we've got 600 troops you mentioned
heading that way to help with this
evacuation on top of 3 000 u.s forces
who are also
going to be in kabul over the next
couple of days helping with the u.s exit
u.s officials very mindful of the
comparison that is increasingly being
made to the final few days in saigon in
1975 wanting to avoid that image of
helicopters off the roof of the embassy
that was so um so such a damning image
of that adventure of that venture in in
vietnam so many decades ago clearly the
uh the the effect the impact of these
failures in afghanistan are going to
haunt the presidency of joe biden for
the rest of his time i believe
okay deborah thank you
now nhs bosses say tens of thousands of
people could be putting their lives at
risk by not coming forward for cancer
checks and research suggests it's
because people don't want to burden the
nhs in the wake of the pandemic but they
say they're ready and open and they're
urging anyone with symptoms to come
forward let's talk to the nhs national
clinic and clinical director for cancer
professor peter johnson good morning to
you i mean look i know in in i think
it's jude is it this last year we've
seen a huge increase in the number of
cancer treatments being carried out and
because
you think that's because people have
been leaving it for 12 months
good morning stephen yes absolutely the
nhs obviously has been working very hard
to make sure that people who might have
symptoms of cancer can get checked out
and i think we saw about a quarter of a
million people in june
to check them out and about 27 000
people started on cancer treatment so
things are open things are up and
running but we do know that over the
last year or so we've seen around 10
percent less people than we would have
expected for treatment with cancer and
that means that people are out there and
that they may have symptoms that they
haven't been bringing forward and we
know that people are understandably
cautious and worried that the nhs is
under pressure but equally it's very
very important that if they have got
symptoms if they've got things like
discomfort in the stomach diarrhea
that's been going on for three weeks
blood in their pee even just the once or
they've got a cough that's been going on
for three weeks or more that they we
really want them to come forward because
it is so important because if we catch
cancer early that's when we have the
best possible chance of curing it
it's part of the issue here not just
that i mean people don't want to be a
burden on the nhs and we get that
um but the fact that if you've got a
symptom which you know you could you
could maybe think with something else
it's
it it's easier to ignore than trying to
get even an initial gp appointment i
mean they're they're not easy to get
hold of at the moment
my colleagues in general practice are
working incredibly hard of course
they're rolling out the vaccine program
they're seeing lots of people and and
many things are not normal a lot of
consultations taking place over the
telephone but they are also very
committed to making sure that people if
they have got symptoms can be seen so
you will be seen and it may not be in
quite the normal way you may need to
start with a telephone call
but people will be seen and it's really
important that if people have got
symptoms that they do come forward
because if we don't know about them we
can't help them but if we do know as i
say the sooner we know the better
because that's when the chance of being
cured is highest
is is part of the issue here
that people aren't always aware what the
symptoms are
i think that's right it's surprising
that that around two-thirds of people
aren't aware that prolonged bloating or
pain in the stomach could be a sign of
early cancer and i think it is so
important that if things aren't right
for you and people know what's normal
for them generally speaking and if
you're not right please do come and see
us because we really do want to get you
checked out
are you hopeful things can get back on
track comparatively quickly i mean
is the system equipped to cope with an
increase in people if that happens
well we've we've prioritized the
investigation and treatment of cancer
throughout the pandemic and although of
course things were very disrupted early
in in 2020 we rapidly got them back on
track during the summer of last year and
we saw a much smaller effect on the
numbers of people coming forward and the
numbers of people starting treatment
during the wave of coronavirus that we
saw in january and so
we're seeing record numbers at the
moment and it is really important to
emphasize that the service is there for
people if they need it
okay professor good to talk to you this
morning thank you thank you
now almost 600 people attempted to cross
the english channel on thursday and
that's a new daily record the home
office says more than 11 000 people have
now crossed the dover strait since the
start of the year
at least 38 people have died in flash
floods in northern turkey which have
destroyed bridges closed roads and cut
off electricity to hundreds of villages
it's the second natural disaster to hit
turkey this month with wildfires
ravaging the southern coastal regions
now this is an interesting one this is a
cave lion cub that was alive
28 000 years ago it's been discovered
preserved in siberian permafrost it's a
female cub scientists are amazed at just
how well preserved it is and think it
may even can
contain
traces of its mother's milk
now with the last of team gb's athletes
back in the uk it's time to celebrate a
weekend long homecoming will take place
across the country celebrating the
achievements of the team starting with
an event today
at the london stadium
decent weather for a party for a
celebration though kirsty it's always
weather to celebrate oh quite right
yes always but actually it is looking
pretty decent in the london area today
and for many of us there is some dry and
bright weather around but i have to say
we do have some pesky weather fronts
moving in off the atlantic and that does
mean we're going to see some cloudy
skies and some outbreaks have been
trying to nudge in through this weekend
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning for many of us it's going
to be a bit of a mixed bag of weather
this weekend we've got weather fronts
pushing off the atlantic bringing with
it some cloudier skies and outbreaks of
rain already sitting in across parts of
southern ireland that's going to start
pushing its way a little bit further
east through the rest of the day so make
the most of any sunshine this morning we
have got some showers again across parts
of scotland quite breezy here the
showers though should be a little bit
lighter than yesterday and we'll start
to ease as the wind eases through the
day now we'll see the clouds thickening
up through parts of wales the midlands
later on northern england as the weather
fronts slide in from the west
in the sunshine across the southeast
today you could see 23 or 24 so actually
feeling fairly pleasant but we do have
the cloudier skies moving into northern
england and then also in northern
ireland and the weather front grinds to
a halt here overnight it's really just
fairly light rain and drizzle more
showers coming in across southern
ireland later and also the far north of
scotland and the northern isles could
see some showers overnight bit of a gray
start on sunday we've got further
outbreaks of rain around eventually
we'll start to see some brighter skies
pushing in from the north
now the united states is accelerating
efforts to
evacuate people from kabul this weekend
as the taliban continues its advance
towards the afghan capital president
biden has said he does not regret the
decision to withdraw troops in the
country despite critics calling it a
significant misjudgment well let's talk
to alistair campbell who is the
government's director of communications
under tony blair at the outset of the
afghan war 20 years ago morning to you
alice i mean 20 years on does it it does
this look like it's it's wiping away
everything and anything that was
achieved
well there's certainly the danger that's
where it ends and i think that's why
people have to
accept that this you know this is this
is just some to a very large extent the
responsibility of those who now appear
to be walking away and
you know i hear what you what joe biden
says when he says it's not a
capitulation and when he says that
there's he has no regrets but i think
it's impossible
not to regret that what is happening on
the ground now
is happening and i was listening
yesterday to a an interview with the
dutch head of the uh
the organization actually against hunger
and he was being asked you know are we
witnessing the you know the could there
be a humanitarian catastrophe he says
i'm looking outside the window and it's
happening now
so i get completely why you know the
british media will focus on getting
british nationals out the american media
will focus on getting american nationals
out but it's what's happening on the
ground there now that is utterly
horrific
and we're kidding ourselves if we don't
think that the consequences of that are
going to
be with us for a very very long time and
have a direct impact on our on our
security and our strategic interests i
mean in some respects i don't know if
people are necessarily thinking
um you know we need to get our people
out urgently and that's our priority i
think an awful lot of people are
thinking the best part of 500 uh young
lives young british lives were lost and
was it worth it well i think obviously
if you're one of the families of the 457
british or 2 400 american soldiers who
lost your lives you bound to be thinking
well why did we do that and all that all
i think we can say to that is actually
that afghanistan did make for all the
problems massive progress and that is
now being put
at
risk
and so yes i think you can make the case
that those who fought and died
in afghanistan were fighting for
something good and they did make massive
progress
but this now is just i think such a
catastrophe that's unfolding and look
you have to remember about joe biden he
was always a bit of an afghan skeptic if
you go back to
2009-10 he was a massive opponent of the
so-called surge under president obama
when thirty thousand troops went in he
always felt that the strategy should be
one of
counter insurgency and counterterrorism
rather than nation building now it's
true as boris johnson said last night
there may no there is no clear military
solution right now on offer but that
doesn't mean there are other things that
we can and should be doing and i just
can't see the urgency where where's all
the kind of discussion going on between
the world leaders what are the you know
nato i heard reports from some of the
smaller countries at the recent nato
conference that when they were trying to
raise what will happen if this trump
deal is followed through there's just a
kind of complete pull out
if they said they were met by kind of
eyebrow rolling of some of the bigger
countries you just felt we've been here
20 years you've got to get out and so i
think there's an awful lot that can be
done that should be done
and the humanitarian side alone i think
we're really going to see
the folly of the decision to get rid of
the the
department for international development
because the humanitarian fallout from
this is going to be enormous but well
what what can be done in practical terms
because you say
a lot of this comes down to the
negotiations that president trump
carried out with the taliban of course
people now turning around and saying
well you can't believe a word they say
in negotiations because they're going
back on that agreement now as as we're
seeing so if there is no immediate
military strategy we can employ what can
be done
well the only thing you can do
you have to have a military and
diplomatic strategy going on at the same
time now with
what
what's made that so difficult certainly
in the short term and possibly in the
medium and long term as well because
let's just be honest if this does
go the whole way and i it's obvious it
seems to me that what the the afghan
authorities are doing
is sort of thinking right well we have
to defend kabul at all costs but let's
just say that doesn't happen then let's
not pretend that this is not going to be
a problem that affects all of us and you
you started rightly your report by going
back 20 years ago
i mean we do have such short memories
why did this whole thing start it
started because of the link with the
terrorist networks which then
committed the atrocity of 911 which we
we
we've all had to live with the
consequences since so i do think on the
humanitarian front has to be far greater
urgency
the you know and i really are the the
people that i kind of
sort of lie awake at night worrying
about are the people who have been
living there in afghanistan afghans who
helped the brits who helped the
americans now is enough being done to
make sure that they're safe to help them
get them get get get out will they
actually be offered any kind of proper
proper exile so these are all things
that require
the kind of urgency that you know i just
didn't see last night it's all very well
for boris johnson to call a cobra
meeting and just because we can't do
everything doesn't mean that we could
that there is nothing that we can be
doing right now and i think there has to
be a mobilization of the well see
where's the united nations i've seen
statements from guterres but what you
know are these guys meeting are they
sitting down going through all of the
problems that we're facing short medium
and long term because they are enormous
alistar campbell we've got to leave it
there thank you thank you
okay let's see what the weather's going
to do for you today good morning kirsty
good morning stephen it's very formal it
is very formal it is i'm feeling quite
formal this morning um overcast today
for some places yeah we've got weather
fronts are moving in off the atlantic so
at the moment the weather in the uk is
still pretty unsettled but there will be
some smells of sunshine around and i'm
hoping that we might see some warmth in
that sunshine as well today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we've got a low pressure
sitting out in the atlantic here and the
weather fronts associated with that are
spinning into the uk and ireland today
bringing with it fairly cloudy skies and
some light rain and drizzle occasionally
heavy places but for most it's just
persistent cloud it's going to start
sliding in from the west now we do have
sunshine and showers for scotland it's
quite breezy here the showers not as
heavy as yesterday and they'll ease as
the wind eases too for much of ireland
rather cloudy with the rain starting to
slide in here could be heavy in the
south and across wales the midlands and
northern england we'll start to see the
skies clouding over as smart breaks of
rain start to nudge in here the southern
east of england generally speaking
looking largely dry with bright or sunny
spells and temperatures up to around 23
or 24. the cloud with the rain on it
grinds to halt across northern england
and northern ireland overnight and a bit
of a grey start for many tomorrow
okay time for the papers this morning
with the journalist badisha and former
editor of the daily star dawn nissan
mourning both bedisha let's kick
straight off with the financial times
should we um looking i was just talking
to alistair campbell about the taliban
situation in afghanistan i mean
it makes a very concerning reading
it makes for extremely worrying reading
and the ft are looking into the
socio-politics of it but they are
warning us about the facts which is that
the taliban have surrounded the capital
which is kabul they've also captured
kandahar which is the second largest
city and overall they've gained control
of at least 14 of the country's 34
provincial capitals at the same time
leaders from the taliban are in qatar
right now speaking to leaders of other
nations including china india and the uk
and nato have issued a statement saying
that they want a political solution but
my question is what exactly would a
political solution be in this context
you know what it would be it would be
the taliban being put into power backed
by
international forces and backed by other
countries because what we're hearing
from actual afghans who fought the
taliban over the last 20 odd plus years
is that their own leadership are
stepping back
i'm not saying that they're letting the
taliban in but the the kind of
military and political defense and
kickback and resistance hasn't yet
started up yet and what dawn said in a
previous slot is uh absolutely true
which is my worry is not about the us
and the uk embassy staff who indeed are
being evacuated right now it's also
about the ordinary the millions of
ordinary afghan
women children and men who were there in
the country and this is really not a
debate about whether the allied invasion
20 years ago was right or wrong if you
look at the history of the country there
have been successive wars and
occupations and elements of stability
and fragile statehood so
we're not on a war footing yet
but there's very good reason for this
story to be on the front page of all of
the newspapers yeah yeah that's true um
i'm talking front pages on the telegraph
front page
dawn looking at
um
this i don't even want to name it really
this killer in in plymouth
yeah i mean it's it's
it's not a good news morning is it
really in any sense stephen um
every single paper is quite rightly
covering this story and i just want to
give her a
of the daily mirror which i actually
have concentrated on victims
rather than the killer and you know
quite right not to name this this 22
year old creature who
has killed six people in the mass
shooting um including a three-year-old
little girl he was shot on the street
and she pushed her little pram down the
road little toy crown
and your heart aches i mean it's just
absolutely chilling um to to read the
details of what's happened in this
hideous case but the one element that
the telegraph and and a lot of the other
players have picked up on about steven
um
is the fact that this this man and i
don't like to use term mouse is not um
as i was a a woman hating in-cell
extremist now i was not really aware
that this thing even existed but
um it's members of this group um they're
involuntarily celebrate
celibate because they're young men
they're hostile to women because they
they're made they feel they're so
unattractive they'll never get a partner
so
they take it out on women they have this
this hatred of willing for their own
inadequacies it's absolutely chilling
and and this this creature um had a
youtube channel website where he would
he would post his hideous views and
there were so many men stephen flocking
to this before it was taken down saying
this creature was a hero for what he had
done saying yeah women sort of like you
know when we're not condoning what he's
done but you know it's all our you know
it's all women's fault we are like we
are but we are forced to be celibate
it's i didn't even know this existed
it's absolutely shocking and you know
the chilling things six mass shootings
in in america um killing 46 people
by by young men who have similar
feelings and it is quite horrific that
five innocent people have lost their
lives because of this this this man's
hatred of women and and especially
obviously he his first victim was his
own mum i mean it's it's just it's just
hideous stephen and you know thoughts
and prayers it's a cliche but with with
those that have lost loved ones and
everybody in plymouth who must be
absolutely stunned by this it's it's
it's extremely hard to get your head
around isn't it really is
um okay let's change tech have a look at
the express badisha and and the the
ongoing concerns with childhood obesity
yeah this is a longer-range story rather
than another terrible piece of news
that's in the headlines but it is
something we need to think about so
councils are now pointing out to the
government that childhood obesity rates
have risen by a huge percentage uh in
the last five years uh they've gone up
60 percent in the last five years in
type 2 diabetes and they're pointing out
that
the main cause of type 2 diabetes in the
young is actually obesity and they
remind the government that the
government had pledged to halve the
numbers of obese kids by the end of the
decade now that means we have sort of
nine years maybe eight and a half years
left on that
so that's the main story and of course
uh the newspapers always go with the the
spectacular headline and the spectacular
image but
the proposed suggestions i think they're
very constructive they're all about
having healthy eating initiatives in
schools they're all about having
community sports facilities and play
centers and they're all about being
mindful and educated about sports
fitness food and health so
i think that despite the spectacular
headlines about obesity and child
obesity and child diabetes actually the
proposed solutions are very workable and
just need some government investment we
just need do you know i'm a great people
want freedom of choice and i get that i
totally get that but sometimes we need
to have some of the things taken away
from us because i'm a dreadful i'm a
dreadful one for snacking and for crisps
and peanuts and all the rest of it and
it's it's very hard if it wasn't there i
wouldn't do it but it's very hard to say
no to myself
at times um what's this about a hermit
jab dawn in the express
oh this is
it's i love this story steven because
it's it's quite light-hearted take on
obviously what is a very very serious
debate about um the vaccine roll out
around the world and just another shout
out for the british government we've
done exceptionally well on this and just
for once we should be proud of that um
this is a story um and it's about a chat
called panther pictures
who has been
living in a cave in serbia for the past
20 years now he emerged last year and
discovered a blessing that this pandemic
was raging throughout the world he knew
nothing about it we're at a time but i'm
glad to hear he's got his jab thank you
both